bonjour meriem achour bouakaz bonjour
alors vous êtes cinéaste et vous êtes un
moyen depuis 2011
dites moi comment fait-on pour partir de
vétérinaire à cinéaste et ben
effectivement c'était pas du tout prévu
dans mon parcours c'est
suite à une expérience
dans j'ai eu l'occasion de faire un
stage de réalisation
parce que c'était une période de ma vie
où j'ai essayé de trouver un moyen en
fait d'expression mais je me destinais
pas du tout au métier de réalisatrice
donc c'est suite à ce stage là de
réalisation qui m'a permis de faire mon
premier documentaire et qui m'a qui m'a
donné envie de m'engager sur cette voie
c'était un stage aligné à l'est de
l'image et du son de mon nom c'était en
algérie bien avant mon arrivée
donc c'était un projet associatif en
fait il a permis à une dizaine de jeunes
de réaliser un premier film court
métrage et on était encadré en fait pour
toutes les phases
du processus de fabrication du film
c'est grâce à ça que j'ai réalisé un
premier film et qui a bien tourné au
festival et qui m'a c'était vraiment une
découverte d'un moyen puissant tout à
fait alors vous posez vos valises à
montréal en 2011 et vous décidez d'aller
vous formez donc à glee nice c'est bien
ça alors parlez moi de cette expérience
c'est comme je le dit c'est la première
maison qui m'a ouvert ses portes à
montréal céline hisse donc j'ai vu des
affiches dans le métro et
j'ai tenté ma chance j'ai déposé ma
candidature et ça a fonctionné
cela fonctionnait pas ce que je voulais
je voulais consolider un peu ma petite
expérience avec informations en bonne et
due forme et c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai fait avec linus et c'était un
excellent choix pour moi qui arrivais à
montréal qui connaissait personne dans
le milieu
alors vous en repartent et bien très
bien formés très très bien outillé pour
produire pas mal de films et pas mal de
documentaires
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de votre
documentaire sur ces jeunes algériens
qui décide de partir à tout prix
et quand ça ne fonctionne pas eh ben ils
choisissent la solution extrême en
s'immolant par le feu
ça doit être très très dur pour les
familles bien absolument absolument mais
j'aimerais préciser que c'est pas
forcément à cause d'eux
de l'impossibilité de quitter le pays il
y a beaucoup de raisons et une situation
complexe qui pousse qui pousse des
jeunes et pas forcément des jeunes parce
qu'il ya des cas des cas de tout âge à
poser ce geste extrême c'est vraiment
moi je dirais avant tout une rupture
avec l'espoir avec la vie est un besoin
d'exprimer
toute la violence accumulés et qu'on
retourne
contre soi-même pour dire pour crier son
désespoir finalement avant de mourir
c'est un refus de mourir
dans l'anonymat en fait alors dites-moi
qui sont ces jeunes là est ce que c'est
des diplômés est ce que c'est des gens
qui en ont marre du chômage du
sous-emploi de la mauvaise rémunération
souvent souvent il y a toujours un
événement qui fait basculer les choses
un déclic et ce déclic là c'est souvent
une injustice ça peut être ça peut être
un emploi on n'arrive pas à accéder à un
emploi ça peut être un logement quand
vous refusez un logement social
ça peut être une injustice une décision
de justice défavorable ou injuste ça
peut être c'est vraiment les gens se
sentent victimes de mépris ça c'est un
sentiment très très
vif très sensible en algérie les gens se
sentent méprisés par les autorités par
un certain nombre de
deux conditions de vie qui les oppresse
et qui les empêchent d'accéder au
minimum pour se sentir une personne
digne et respectable et
certaines craque et pose ce geste là ça
se passe souvent sur la place publique
face à une institution donc c'est pas un
geste qu'on fait cacher c'est un geste
qu'on fait devant tout le monde pour
crier et montrer sa fin ras-le-bol son
ras-le bol en fait c'est un geste qui en
rappelle un autre celui du jeune mohamed
bouazizi est ce que vous vous en
souvenez ce jeune du tunisien marchand
ambulant de légumes et de fruits qui
s'était donné la mort et qui avait posé
par par cet art là même un acte
fondateur qui allait entraîner de
plusieurs autres sites à de suicide
de la même manière dans le monde en
france on en a eu 50
je sais malabo l'algérie combien de
jeunes se sont suicidés de cette fois
c'est moi alors bien sûr tout le monde
se souvient de bouazizi c'est devenu un
symbole de la révolution tunisienne donc
heureusement elle occupe le principe du
tout le printemps arabe effectivement
mais en algérie c'est un drame plus
silencieux et plus ancien que les
printemps arabes parce que le premier
cas quand j'ai fait mes petites
recherches donc dans le cadre du projet
le premier cas c'était en 2004
donc c'est quand même ça fait ça fait
beaucoup d'années il y a eu un pic au
moment d
des printemps arabes et aujourd'hui il y
en a régulièrement il ya une semaine je
lisais justement un jeune qui a tenté de
s'immoler qui a survécu heureusement
mais c'est assez régulier je peux pas
vous avancer de chiffres mais il y en a
il y en a assez pour que moi ça
m'interpelle et que ça me pose des
questions sur la société algérienne
aujourd'hui
et justement ça vous a interpellé vous
avez parlé aux membres des familles de
ces jeunes là dites moi comment se
sentir
c'est un choc terrible
c'est un choc terrible l'insee c'est
très dur à comprendre accepter c'est ça
dépasse l'entendement
ça dépasse l'entendement et c'est
vraiment un événement traumatique pour
la famille qui malheureusement se trouve
démuni pour pour déchiffrer ce geste et
pour pouvoir survivre à ça en fait
survivre à ça sur le plan social
qu'est ce que ces jeunes là il n'irait
qu'on change dans la société pour
améliorer un peu leur situation
je pense qu'avant tout
c'est un problème d' atteinte à leur
dignité c'est pour moi c'est
profondément c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
pousse les gens à commettre le pire
quelqu'un qui se sent touché blessé dans
sa dignité est capable de commettre le
pire des gestes en l'occurrence celui là
bien sûr il ya les conditions
économiques il ya le chômage il ya
beaucoup de choses mais c'est c'est le
fondement c'est vraiment le le respect
des personnes et de leur liberté
et justement parlant de liberté c'est
quoi le système politique en place en ce
moment est ce qu on a plus de liberté
d'expression il ya des élections
présidentielles qui se prépare et
bouteflika vient d'annoncer sa
candidature pour un 5ème monde
donc la situation est un peu tendue en
ce moment puisque les algériens ne
savent pas trop comment se mouvant se
dérouler ces élections ni quelles sont
les possibilités qui vont s'offrir donc
aux gens donc de mary soif de changement
et non vite
de renouveau sa bouille jerry ça
bouillonne
ça a toujours été comme ça c'est il y a
il ya une jeunesse qui a soif de vivre
il y a des forces humaines vraiment un
potentiel humain très riche et qui ne
demande qu'à vivre et qu'elle s'est
exprimée et en ce qui concerne le taux
de chômage à quel niveau se situe temps
je sais qu'il ya des chiffres officiels
mais je pense qu'on est con et
que c'est pire que les chiffres avancés
on parle d'un 13% ou par non mais je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus important
que ça et votre documentaire quand est
ce qu'on va le regarder au canada eh
bien j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été
sélectionnés donc au rendez vous du
cinéma québécois donc le film va passer
ce samedi en première dans le cadre du
festival donc des rendez vous du cinéma
québécois
super je vous souhaite d'avoir plein
plein plein de succès merci alors
c'était meriem achour bouakaz je vous
remercie infiniment d'avoir pris le
temps de venir nous voir
merci pour l'invitation au revoir